it tastes a little bit familiar you
remember this one's coming back to you
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we close out season 14 with
stevo the sequel
he's a comedian author and hot ones
legend his latest special gnarly is
currently available on stevo.com
and while you're there check out his
memoir professional idiot his skateboard
decks and as fate would have it he has a
hot sauce
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
that's right stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole at stevo.com
stevo welcome back to hot ones dude
thank you so much for having me
i think it would land about here though
it's not that hot
of course we've got stevo's butthole
destroyer on the way
it's gonna be a lot hotter but hey
[Music]
you know i am intimidated for two
reasons
number one to try to outdo what we did
last time
i mean that that's a tall order classic
number two
last time the wings were pre-prepared
this time
they're not they're just waiting to have
uh
sauce poured directly on them which
means i believe i'm gonna be ingesting a
lot more sauce this time
the classic let's do it
so even by the standards of jackass your
stunt work is the stuff of legend and
you've been involved in some of the
gnarliest falls ever captured on camera
i once saw a video of you jumping off of
a three-story apartment complex
into a five-foot pool what's the key to
diving into shallow water like that
first thank you there is a very crucial
secret to this
when you hit the water you've got to
curve in
because if you go straight in as a six
foot man into a five foot pool
you're gonna have a problem with the
bottom of the pool but by hitting the
water and laying back
and curving in you find yourself sliding
on the bottom of the pool
much like a baseball player might slide
into a base which he is
stealing what's a harsh lesson about
working with explosives that you had to
learn the hard way
oh well i don't know if we can uh
pull back that fourth curtain and reveal
that i'm here in my own living room
but it was here in my own living room
where i played with explosives
for the big climactic ending
scene of my multimedia comedy special
gnarly
the plan was to blow up the living room
in spectacular fashion
and really kind of push the boundaries
of what made sense
and each explosion as ridiculous as it
was
i found left me completely unscathed
and as i kept going further and further
i thought well it's not over until
something
happens you know i gotta get kind of
hurt so i laid down on the floor
in a bed of rocket engine fuel and that
ended up just being more than
i anticipated and just a few short days
later i was getting
skin grafts on 15 of my body
suffice it to say that was the
perhaps the most epic closer to a comedy
special
that the world has ever seen do you have
a favorite professional sports stunt
because i've seen you getting
pelted by pucks at an nhl game and then
you did that thing with the arizona
diamondbacks where you're in front of a
high-speed pitching machine
just wearing balls happy gilmore style
well
again thank you i'm truly flattered
the hockey puck when i was in the hockey
arena was really pretty
mellow compared to the time that i was
trying to have
chuck liddell the ufc hall of famer gave
me cauliflower ear
with an array of different sports
themed stunts we rested a golf ball
on my ear and he wagged my ear with a
golf club
it's almost shocking that my ear didn't
come off we all thought it had
he also uh wagged a hockey puck point
blank
right into my ear but uh yeah in that
one day i would say i did
all of my favorite sports themed stunts
it was
really something else
now i don't want to over promise and
under deliver
by uh pouring a great deal of hot sauce
on these ones and not so much on the end
so i want to be pretty uniform
does that look that looks great
i already know this is going to be a way
harder experience than the last time
a concern that i had the last time was
my esophageal condition
known as barrett's esophagus which is
scary because
it's often a precursor for esophageal
cancer
and i've been like a little bit
sort of careful about like just
gratuitous
damage to my esophagus but my last
endoscopy the gastroenterology
told me i look good i'm stable i'm ready
for hot ones
just in time just in time so you've said
in the past that skateboarders have a
special relationship with the video
camera and even those vhs tapes that
they used to sell at skate shops back in
the day were basically like viral videos
before viral videos even existed
what do you mean when you say that you
found religion through the video camera
oh man i think that as humans
without exception we
struggle with mortality i even go so far
as to say that i think our human
existence
is a prank on us because we only have
one instinct which is to survive
and we only have one guarantee which is
we won't
that's probably the main reason why
people they have children because they
want part of them to live on
have a legacy and other people turn to
religion
to say that even though you're gonna die
you're gonna go to heaven where
everything's gonna be great
and neither of those two uh really
worked for me so i fall into the third
category i identify with
uh which is those who
leave stuff behind to be remembered by
and you know i point to
cavemen who would uh draw stick figures
on the wall in the cave
evidently because they knew those stick
figures would outlive them
and this is how i found religion in a
video camera because
every video that i made i knew had the
potential to
entertain people to inspire people after
i was physically gone
so i felt very much that the video
camera
allowed me to defeat mortality it
allowed me to live forever it's my
heaven you know
it's my religion
if i keep it up like that then i'm in
real trouble i know
i don't want to go one step forward two
steps back with the esophagus stevo all
right
it's like head trauma and nut kicks
i saved them for special occasions
i'm flattered and i'm honored you know
last time we talked about
how you ripped up fame from mlp's studio
after you lost your rolex but the part
of your hip-hop era that i'm most
interested in
is you rolling with 50 cents crew g unit
there for a while between
young buck 50 cent and tony ayo
who gave you like the most welcoming
embrace into that crew
i would say young buck i'd also say 50
cent himself
as we showed up walking from the tour
bus into the hotel
somebody's trying to tap me and said hey
come over here
and they directed me into this little rv
and there's 50 cents sitting on the sofa
he's all excited yeah you know he's so
cool
and um i asked him to throw me down the
stairs in the bellhop cart
in that situation you gotta wonder who
stands to lose more
right i mean there's me i could have
been paralyzed very easily
but there's 50 cent he was on top of the
world
untold millions so yeah 50 was really
cool especially when i said hey can i
get you to leave my voicemail greeting
i kept that voicemail greeting for years
and thank god i've got that footage for
you
hey what's up [ __ ] this is 50
cent steve well busy right now you
understand what i'm saying to you
so what you can do is you can leave a
message so you can call back
matter of fact you don't even want to
talk to you [ __ ] but you know what
leave a message anyway yeah actually
[ __ ] off
[Laughter]
okay we're on to this one now it's
called hellfire dude
how psyched were you on that saturday
night live skit
dude my phone just started going nuts
you know like
people just like text me like crazy i
turned on the tv and
the thing that i was so fascinated by is
you know sometimes you wonder i wonder
like
how snl would parody me like what would
they do and i think for me you could be
like
oh maybe you do like the big exaggerated
hand gestures or something but what
mikey day did
is i do this thing where i play piano on
the table and he was doing that so it
was
cool to see like the little things that
they pick up on from you
and then like how that plays out so i'll
remember that forever that was awesome
just uh validation and the fabric of pop
culture
and that you know but speaking of the
numbers i'm dying to know
with the pandemic and having to shoot so
many of these episodes remotely
has that negatively impacted the
performance
yeah i think like it's it's not i think
there's a couple things at play like
one everybody's like timelines pushback
so it's not like people are like
on a press tour necessarily you know
it's not like they come to new york and
they're doing
hot ones in the afternoon and then
they're doing fallon across the street
nothing like doing this that the other
thing so because like in hollywood
everybody's thing is messed up
like our system is totally messed up too
along with it
but to our fans credit you know they've
been showing up so to the fans oh yeah
to the fans right if this episode
doesn't perform quite as well as my
first one i'm blaming it on the pandemic
okay last calientes now you're not using
this wall of hot sauce to disguise how
much
is going on your wings are is there no
like look at you can see
woof i am uh but a humble chicken wing
host
but i am an honorable one yeah i love
that man i love that dude
and uh as you know apart from the chorus
i'm sticking on a really scary path
[Laughter]
all right steve as you may recall we
have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that gram where we do a
deep dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context
so i'll show you the picture you just
tell us the bigger story yeah
so here you are on monday night raw it
looks like you're begging for your life
and as
i understand it this is not acting not
acting at all
oh man that was definitely the worst
beating i ever took
and prior to shooting jackass 4 i would
argue perhaps the worst concussion i
ever had damn um
but uh there we were promoting jackass
number two
in uh the ring on monday night raw the
big final move was umaga the samoan
bulldozer
climbing on the top rope diving off and
just
body slamming me as i lay on the ground
there the thing is that in the wwe
the match isn't over as long as you're
still reacting
you kind of have to play dead and i did
not play dead i was rolling around like
reacting like oh
you know like and so umaga felt
disrespected that no no no it's
and it's not over because you're still
moving around he kept going
and going because i kept moving around i
didn't know and he dropped his elbow
it's the last thing i remember really
and they cut to commercial
because it got so dark they never showed
me leaving the ring
i remember coming to in like a control
room
where my jackass comrade chris pontius
who i was with
describes that vince mcmahon was just
jazzed
there was great like yeah and uh
yeah that was some serious head drama
man i was beating into a blackout
so far i'm hanging tough
at the end of gnarly you thank the
[ __ ] [ __ ] who didn't think it
belonged on their platform
do you ever feel misunderstood by the
network fat cats or the streaming
services gatekeepers and comedy
i love that question and thank you for
it you know
as i put together this hour of comedy
which would ultimately become my gnarly
special
i had one night while i was performing
my head exploded i thought oh my god i'm
telling these stories in my stand-up
routine which for the most part
all transpired on camera so what if i
put together a comedy special where
you're watching me perform the act
however much like hot ones footage is
interstitially edited
in to illustrate the stories being told
i thought wow
this is completely original there's
never been a multimedia comedy special
like that
i just believed in it so much i funded
the whole thing i brought it to
netflix hbo showtime and those places
took the position that they didn't want
to be in the business of
steve-o stand-up comedy somehow seeing
me as
the jackass guy and not taking me
seriously as a crossover
into stand-up comedy they just didn't
want to mess with it despite it being
really something special i was
heartbroken by that
but i didn't let it stop me figured out
a way to put it out on my own website
and i've actually done very well with it
i've proven what it was worth and that
the next time around when i
do my bucket list special oh they're
gonna [ __ ]
have to pay me man or i'll just do the
same thing again
[Music]
all right i can't start [ __ ] bitching
out now
i never forget last time fighting
through it because i
really didn't want to waste any of the
time i had to convey you know
really respecting the platform and the
audience i really wanted to communicate
through everything which world record
means more to you
having the highest porta potty launch
ever recorded or breaking the most
light bulbs with your nuts there are
kids all over the world for decades
breaking these light bulbs but i don't
think anybody
has been launched in a port-a-potty with
bungee cords attached to cranes
to begin with let alone as high as i was
so i'm going with the port-a-potty
and you know some fans want autographs
other fans they want selfies but your
fans they want you to kick them in the
nuts
what's the most creative way a fan has
ever asked you to kick them in the nuts
it happened recently i believe on
halloween of
2019 this kid asked me really
passionately and i said you know what
i don't do that anymore but if you can
come up with an idea that is just so
creative
that i have to do it then we'll see and
i told this to a few people before
but this kid came back and he said i've
got it
we're both in a handstand it's the
upside down nut kick
a tomahawk chop with your foot while
you're both in a handstand and i saw it
i said
absolutely let's do it it's the only nut
kick i've done in a
long time and just like concussions and
nut kicks
that one counted
[Music]
you can't be a [ __ ] now right is that
is that decent that's very decent
it's beyond decent trust me that's
plenty that's plenty
okay good tastes a little bit familiar
you remember this one's coming back to
you
so i understand that you have dreams of
creating an animal sanctuary where you
can one day
live out the rest of your years
surrounded by noah's ark of creatures
have you thought out what exactly that
would look like stevo's wide world of
animals
yeah thank you for asking this one um
my girl and i lux and this is an
engagement ring that i wear
lex and i decided instead of having kids
we would like to pour ourselves into
helping animals
we want to open up an animal sanctuary
where we're going to live out our years
but i also think less about having it be
a destination
and more of a place that's sort of a
self-sustaining farm where we grow our
own food and it's a little bit of a
retreat that we don't even want to draw
attention to
and have yes tons of animals
[Music]
the eye of the scorpion
how do you like that for my next version
of my hot sauce the super hot one
stevo's butthole
destroyer i think you know what when i
saw stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
i said to myself he nailed it this guy
gets it
he's figured it out but now i'm ready
whoa
i think i might
be careful
how's that look uh uh a sight to behold
wow everyone's looking pretty hot yup
be careful that's a lot i respect the
platform sean
salute steve hot sauce
you've been a staple at ufc events for
years do you have an all-time favorite
fight that you've ever watched ringside
oh yeah oh yeah robert whittaker against
joelle romero
i believe it was rematch too this
happened in chicago
in june of 2018.
um it's my first time actually getting
tickets from dana white
and we got the tickets and it said row
one we were like yeah right by the
octagon
now what's interesting is that the
reason i was in chicago was to go to a
spiritual conference to hear
neil donald walsh who uh is known for
the conversations with god series i was
i talked i said you know yeah i really
love your books i had to
ask him a couple questions about god and
spirituality
well i said you know what's weird we're
going from here
to a ufc event to watch the most violent
form of physical
combat that's legal
and you know is that okay
he said uh he said that he wouldn't
choose to do it himself but by all means
we should go and enjoy ourselves
yeah yeah the fight between you all
romero and robert whittaker was a banger
could have gone either way i might have
given it to whittaker frankly
yeah i mean don't don't be mistaken by
my casual demeanor like i'm on fire
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how's that i gotta add more i think
just to keep up it's how much i love you
i love you too
i love you too stevo cheers
[Music]
all right stevo here we are at the
conclusion of our hotline sequel we've
talked about your roots as a fire
breathing clown and then taking it all
the way through to
inspirational comedian and all the trips
to the emergency room
that have connected those things is
someone who's experienced
every type of physical pain you can
possibly think of
what do you think of as the best analogy
for the wings of death
on the spectrum of body discomfort
i think i might have to maybe do
i don't even have to ask you who you
think is the king of hot ones we know
it's gordon ramsay right i mean that guy
was an absolute maniac on this show so
i'm not willing
to call it here okay i'm going to take
it one step further
i want everybody to know that this steve
owens hot toss for your butthole is
available on amazon
as well as stevo.com and it is
delicious wow
yeah that last minute was really
unnecessary man
closing season 14 the only way we know
how
a love letter to the day one fans i
got right in there whoa
with stevo chugging a bottle of hot
sauce and going straight to the eyes
now there's nothing left to do but throw
out the red carpet for you steve
this camera that camera probably just
the one you're looking at
let the people know what you have going
on in your life
yeah i got my my podcast
called stevo's wild ride wild ride with
stevo
just put up the mark cuban episode
that's a pretty big deal
got a lot of big stars on there
ah i've remained quite prolific with my
youtube channel my main youtube channel
that is
nothing sucks on there check it out
jackass 4 is scheduled for release in
september
i'm also now a professional skateboarder
it's a dream as i've had a really long
time how
cool ah
i think that'll do it follow me on
instagram
a little bit ah my cards
thank you guys
say hello to apollo the last dab apollo
here's my
30 second review for what it's worth
this is the hottest last dab sauce that
we've ever made
by a lot i'm actually not even sure if
that's a selling point but it's just
fair warning
the last dab apollo it has that deep
rich complex flavor profile that
smokinet is known for
deep heavy diesel pepper big
extreme heat you don't have to if you
don't want to but if you want to
heatness.com heatness.com heatness.com
to get your hands on the last dab apollo
around here we call it the gold label
you